si estamos lidiando con dos dimensiones
y queremos encontrar el área bajo la
curva contamos con buenas herramientas
para realizar esto y recordamos que
estas herramientas digamos si este es el
eje xy este es el eje y entonces déjenme
dibujar les algunas funciones
arbitrarias aquí digamos que esta es una
función
fx y que queremos encontrar el área
entre x igual a a
muy bien y x igual a b eso lo dijimos
hace muchos muchos muchos muchos vídeos
anteriores que es tomando secciones muy
estrechas o pequeños cambios en x y que
de hecho las llamamos delta x vamos a
poner de equis en este caso súper
infinitamente pequeños cambios en x y
luego lo multiplica menos lo
multiplicamos por fx así que realmente
lo que estamos haciendo son rectángulos
muy muy estrechos es decir estamos
tomando f x por la de x y esto nos da el
área infinitamente estrecha de este
rectángulo justo aquí y puesto que estos
elementos son infinitamente pequeños
vamos a tener una infinidad de ellos
para rellenar todo el espacio verdad y
así la herramienta que usamos fue la
integral definida la integral es una
suma una suma infinita de estas áreas
infinitamente pequeñas
y la anotación que usamos iría de ave y
hemos hecho muchos vídeos sobre cómo
evaluar estas cosas yo solo quiero
recordarlo conceptualmente lo que esto
está diciendo tomemos un pequeño
entonces cambio en x muy lo
multiplicamos por la altura en este
punto y vamos a tener una infinidad de
estos x porque las x son super pequeñas
así que tomamos la suma de todos ellos
que es tomarnos la integral desde a
hasta b y eso es justo nuestra integral
definida estándar ahora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es extender un poco
digamos podría resolver problemas más
duros o una clase más amplia de
problemas así que vamos a pensar ahora
que estamos en tres dimensiones y yo
acabo de dibujar aquí el plano xy solo
voy a mantener eso solo para digamos
hacer una comparación aunque tengamos un
poco de perspectiva pero digamos que
ahora este es el eje y
digamos que se va por detrás de la
pantalla
y este va a ser nuestro eje x justo aquí
muy bien este será el eje x digamos que
tengo algún camino una trayectoria en el
plano xy para definir realmente en el
plano x lo tengo que parametrizar tanto
la variable x como la vara y la variable
y verdad así que digamos que x es igual
a 2 mejor déjenme cambiar de colores
para que sea divertido ya use mucho este
digamos que x es igual a una función que
te baja y digamos que ya es otra función
hdt muy bien con el mismo parámetro y
digamos que vamos a empezar
desde que te es mayor o igual que a que
sea menor o igual que ve ahora está
definida un camino en el plano x y xi
esto puede resultar confuso quizás
quiera revisar los videos de las
ecuaciones paramétricas pero básicamente
cuando t es igual a vamos a tener un
extremo de nuestra trayectoria correcto
entonces vamos a tener que x es heather
y h perdón que es igual a hd a así que
tendremos un punto en el plano xy puede
ser no sé voy a apuntar uno aleatorio
aquí así que cuando te es igual a
dibujamos gba
en la coordenada x y además hd a en
nuestra coordenada allí así que cuando
evaluamos en cada t tanto la función g
como h nos va dando puntos del recorrido
de esta trayectoria así hasta que
alcancemos cuando te vale ok que más o
menos puede ser algo así es una curva
una trayectoria en el plano xy muy bien
es decir cómo se relaciona con lo
anterior ahora bueno déjenme escribir
aquí vamos digamos que tengo una función
asociada a todo el plano es decir tengo
una función f
una función f que depende tanto de x
como de g
ahora lo que hace es asociar a cada
punto del plano un valor real
digamos déjenme dibujar la gráfica de
este fin
voy a usar un color diferente digamos
llamémosle a este el eje z o el eje f
pero algún eje vertical vamos a pintar y
para cada punto del plano vamos a poner
un valor en el eje vertical que está
dado por la función f x y así que puedo
dibujar esto justamente como una
superficie esto lo voy a hacer en
ejemplos concretos en vídeos anteriores
perdón posteriores pero déjenme usar un
color diferente vamos a pintar la
superficie o una parte de ella de lo que
me resulta de la gráfica de la función
de fx y esto es fx y recordemos que todo
esto es me das una x me das una y le
aplicas efe y va a darme un número real
que lo voy a pintar en el eje vertical
ahora digamos que fx de ye podría ser no
sé x más puede ser x porque son sólo
ejemplos de cómo pueden ser estas
funciones así que si x es 1 y que es 2
entonces tendría este x igual a 1 x 2 ok
entonces como pintamos la gráfica pues
simplemente es una superficie ahora
queremos descubrir no el área bajo esta
curva eso era muy fácil en el caso
anterior ahora sí imaginamos que esta
curva nos define una cortina o una valla
que recorre esa curva puedes pensar esto
como como un largo camino
yendo justo desde el eje
perdón desde el punto a cuando te vale
hasta ve y se imagina un muro que va
recorriendo toda esa línea pero sobre la
superficie lo mejor voy a tratar de
dibujarlo digamos
este es el valor que va tomando la
función f a lo largo de la curva y que
sobre la superficie se puede pintar de
forma parecida así así que este punto se
digamos corresponde desde que pintó acá
arriba así si te imaginas tienes una
cortina y fx y es como el techo lo que
he dibujado aquí es la parte en la parte
de abajo es como un muro en esta especie
de curva medio loca así que déjenme
dejen de dibujarlo un poco diferente
para que sea un poquito más claro
este punto digamos corresponder a algún
punto de acá arriba depende de dónde se
intersecta no sé cómo sea pero bueno más
o menos este es el dibujo y para
ayudarte a visualizar déjenme sombrear
para hacer esto un poco más sólido
eso es ahora tienes este muro de forma
curvada aquí y el objetivo principal de
este vídeo es cómo podemos averiguar el
área de este muro que está curvo es en
esencia el
el muro o la valla que se forma en esta
curva si saltamos por arriba y tocas el
techo de fx 10 así que pensemos un poco
si usamos únicamente la analogía que
hice anteriormente podríamos decir bueno
vamos a tomar un pequeño cambio en la
distancia de nuestra curva en la
longitud de la curva y que vamos a
llamarla digamos en bs ese es un pequeño
desplazamiento en la curva en la curva
justo ahí y si multiplico este por el
valor fx y en este punto voy a obtener
el área de de ese rectángulo verdad de
ese pequeño rectángulo justo allí es
cierto
así que si tomamos de ese el cambio en
en la longitud de arco de la curva
déjenme déjenme escribir de ese es un
super super pequeño
cambio
en el en la longitud de arco de la curva
de nuestro camino ese va a ser nuestro t
es de ese perdón así puedes imaginar que
a lo largo de mi muro de s lo voy a
convertir déjenme ponerlo como una
mayúscula de s veces la altura es decir
de s por fx y ahora si sumo todos los
rectángulos estrechos de anchura
infinitamente pequeña entonces tenemos
una suma infinita de todos estos
elementos y desde donde desde que te
empieza en nada y termina en b
justamente desde que estamos en el
primer punto hasta el último dónde
termina la curva y eso me define mi área
estoy solo usando la misma lógica que
usé en los vídeos anteriores no estoy
siendo matemáticamente muy riguroso pero
estamos agarrando esto de base para
construir el muro que está curvado y ver
cómo se construye el área
pero a lo mejor estás diciendo oye ni
siquiera sé cómo calcular esto mírate en
una de ese una xy y una t qué puedo
hacer con esto si son variables muy
distintas
vamos a ver algún progreso y te prometo
que cuando lo hagamos en un ejemplo el
producto final de este vídeo va a ser
menos difícil de entender eso será
cuando lo hagamos en un problema más
concreto y verás que realmente no es
demasiado difícil de utilizar pero
veamos si podemos obtener todo esto en
términos de t antes que nada bueno vamos
a centrarnos en ds así que déjenme
déjeme pintar nuevamente la curva así
que vamos a usar otro color para que no
sea monótono digamos que
vamos a tomar este lg y ahora este va a
ser mi eje x
y así este camino de aquí
se parecería algo más o menos como esto
no si lo pintara de forma correcta este
es mi camino mi mi arco y cuando te es
igual a entonces tenemos el primer punto
y cuando te des igual tenemos el otro
extremo del mismo modo sólo volvía a
colocar la curva que tenía anteriormente
pero de forma digamos este derechita así
que este de ese es lo moradito que estoy
pintando digamos es un pequeño cambio en
la longitud de arco y ahora como
relacionamos de ese y a cambios pequeños
o infinitamente pequeños de xy de ella
bueno si pensamos en eso no estoy siendo
muy riguroso pero pero quiero que
mostrarte el concepto correcto
digamos que podemos poner este cambio
pequeño en equis y este cambio pequeño
en y aquí son los cambios pequeñísimos
que me definen este cambio de s así que
estamos pintando de xy de cambios
pequeñísimos en x y de y entonces a
partir del teorema de pitágoras podemos
descubrir descubrir quién es de s pues
simplemente va a ser la raíz cuadrada de
la suma de los catetos al cuadrado que
en este caso es de x cuadrada más de iu
al cuadrado
perfecto así que parece que un poco a
poco podemos de ese de repente ponerlo
en términos de equis y así que déjenme
si déjenme reescribir esta expresión
poniendo esta raíz recuerden no estoy
siendo totalmente riguroso con lo de las
derivadas pero creo que esto le da
muchísimo sentido así que podemos decir
que esta integral para la cortina
curveada va a ser la integral desde a
hasta b de fx y siempre en lugar de
poner de s voy a poner esta raíz la raíz
cuadrada de de x al cuadrado más de y al
cuadrado ahora por lo menos nos
deshicimos de esta gran s pero no hemos
resuelto el problema de cómo resolver
una integral definida en xy pero con los
valores de dt desde hasta b así que
necesitamos ponerlo todo en términos de
t pero sabemos que xy son funciones de t
así que podemos
escribir lo como
calculamos la integral desde que este es
a hasta d df de x que depende de t y que
también es una función de t así que
ponemos que también depende de esta 7 si
tú me das una t seré capaz de decirte
cuánto vale x cuánto vale ye y después
cuánto vale la f y luego colocamos esta
raíz cuadrada que voy a pintar en
naranja que es de x cuadrada más d
cuadrada y eso le sacábamos la raíz aún
no hemos terminado
necesitamos un dt en la raíz para poder
terminar y veremos cómo aplicar esto en
un problema concreto en el próximo vídeo
así que yo quiero darte la idea de cómo
es que se obtiene la fórmula una cosa
que podemos hacer si nos permitimos
manipular algebraica mente las derivadas
lo que podemos es multiplicar y dividir
por dt así que de un modo vamos a pensar
sobre eso déjenme poner esta parte
naranja de este lado con otro color
digamos esto es lo que teníamos en la
raíz de x cuadrada más d cuadrada y
digamos que lo multiplicamos por dt
sobre de t que digamos realmente es
multiplicar por 1 verdad
o el dt es un cambio muy pequeño en t
así que esta parte de abajo que circule
la vamos a meter en la raíz así que esto
nos queda uno sobre de t por la raíz de
de x cuadrada más d cuadrada y luego
multiplica al adt que estaba arriba muy
bien sólo para mostrar como como lo voy
a separar aquí
ahora yo lo que quiero es esta de té
meterla dentro de la raíz así que esto
será lo mismo solo sólo permite de
permite creer que no estoy haciendo nada
oscuro con la con el álgebra esto es
meterlo pero al cuadrado verdad y esto
va a multiplicar a de x cuadrada más de
ye cuadrada y todo esto va a
multiplicarse por de t correcto no hice
nada solo solo metí el dt al cuadrado
dentro de la raíz para que realmente
significa que no esté haciendo yo nada y
bueno manipulando algebraica mente está
utilizando la propiedad distributiva
tenemos que es de x / dt todo eso al
cuadrado más de iu sobre de t al
cuadrado
ahora de x sobre dt es justo la derivada
de x
al cuadrado lo mismo pasa con ye lo cual
es bastante interesante ahora
sustituyamos esta expresión y voy a
cambiar los colores solo para que haya
claridad esto será la integral desde que
t es igual a déjenme mostrarles de nuevo
el dibujo
hasta que te sigo al ave de fx te coma 7
es decir que f depende de ambas
variables y ahora en lugar de estas de
xy de yes que teníamos
voy a reescribir la raíz cuadrada como
la derivada de x respecto dt al cuadrado
más la derivada de ye respecto al t al
cuadrado o lo que es lo mismo las
derivadas de d g y de h
verdad es lo mismo que la derivada de gt
la derivada de x es lo mismo que la
derivada de g aquí está del lado
izquierdo es la función que describe o
que parametrizar a perdón a x y la
derivada de ye respecto de t es la
derivada de h así que esto lo deja mucho
más claro conocemos esas dos funciones y
por lo tanto también su derivada al
respecto de lo que queda dentro de la
raíz cuadrada sería la derivada de x
respecto de t al cuadrado más la
derivada de y respecto de t al cuadrado
y todo esto por dt y ésta podría
aparecer una fórmula algo extraña y
compleja pero es realmente algo que
sabemos calcular con muchísimo cuidado
así que el problema de la longitud de
arco o de la integral de línea porque
realmente lo que estamos haciendo es una
integral sobre una curva en lugar de
hacerlo sobre un intervalo sobre el eje
x hemos tomado esta extraña integral de
línea y la hemos puesto en términos de
la lo
de arco y de xy de iu y luego todos lo
pasamos a la variable t todo fue todo
pudo ser expresado en función de t de
modo que se convierte en una simple
integral definida yo creo que va a saber
perfectamente bien qué pasa cuando lo
hagamos en un ejemplo y solo para
recordarte de dónde viene todo esto esta
parte de la derecha solo fue un cambio
en la longitud de arco y este es solo la
altura de la función en ese punto
correcto y estamos solo resumiéndolo y
haciendo una suma de longitud es
infinita infinitamente pequeñas y bueno
esto tiene por supuesto una anchura
infinitamente pequeña después lo
multiplicamos por la la altura nos da el
área de rectángulos y esta integral
definida nos dará lo que es el área